in Europe three of the country's hardest
hit by the coronavirus have each
recorded their highest single day death
count their France Spain and Italy where
the spike came despite a national
lockdown over the weekend in Italy
obituaries for victims span 10 pages of
a local newspaper in Bergamo a city in
the northern part of the country empty
as tyub reports from London on how
Europe is fighting to contain the spread
Europe continues to convulse from the
corona virus outbreak cases in Spain are
surging with reported infections over
8,000 this woman just lost her husband
to the virus she too is infected but was
denied treatment from doctors for not
being sick enough desperate to control
their mother her children risking
exposure to themselves across the
continent more than a hundred million
people are now on lockdown
police are even using drones to enforce
it Germany is the latest to slam its
borders shut while in France cafes and
bistros are closed despite local
elections going ahead the British
government is now warning it too could
ban public gatherings and also enforce
months of isolation on the elderly it's
just scary but it's Italy that continues
to suffer the most with a record one day
death toll of 368 people on Sunday alone
still that didn't stop Pope Francis from
walking the streets of an eerily empty
room to pray for the sick prayers which
may have been heard as signs of hope
slowly start to emerge elsewhere like in
China where this all started and in
South Korea also with large outbreaks
the numbers of infected are at record
lows inspiring some Italians to take to
their balconies this weekend to sing
songs of solidarity
including Puccini's classic Nessun Dorma
pincette oh he sings I will win proceed
yes this morning
India's tired London we're all smiling
here to hear that to be real thing